guys this is important this becomes a
foundation for Oliver social media
campaigns for everything you do in
business it's not just social media your
company has to stay in something same
for something that has to make people
feel you have to get people to feel
something to have an emotional
connection to your brand before they're
going to take any action think about
nike okay nike in their commercials in
advertisement in all of their
positioning they don't compare
themselves to reebok they don't talk
about how their shoe was better than
Reebok or better than puma or whatever
the company what does nike do they talk
about athletics they'll throw up a
picture of LeBron James because when you
put on a Nike shoe you feel like you're
a champion that's the feeling that they
get out there you have to make people
feel something with your business first
you may not have you one word right now
okay I see some of them kind of
streaming in you may not have you one
word all figured out right now but this
is such an important exercise guys
because when you're thinking of founding
your next company we're thinking of
bringing on people on your team when
you're thinking about launching your
book we were thinking about creating a
social media campaign it has to embody
this feeling until you do that it's
hopeless it's lost your campaign isn't
going to go anywhere so make people feel
something first and that sets up your
campaign for success